i wanted to follow up on the story of
the paper by jessica rose and peter
mccullough on myocarditis following
covet vaccination
people who watched last week will
remember
that this paper had passed peer review
and was headed towards publication
when the elsevier journal
cardiology journal
replaced the preprint of the paper
with a note saying that had been
temporarily moved
and that
if it was not fully restored the new
version of the paper
would contain an explanation of why it
was temporarily removed
and we pointed out how unusual this was
this wasn't a paper being rejected
because of some issue this wasn't the
authors were literally not told what the
problem was that was highly unusual
and
in any case it suggested some kind of
behind-the-scenes shenanigans that we
are left to guess at and of course on a
topic where we are told there's a
scientific consensus and you should
follow it and the answer is well why is
there a scientific consensus here's a
paper that ran against that consensus
and suddenly mysterious things are
happening to it and i must say many
people wagged their finger at me when i
tweeted about this and said you're
imagining things stuff goes on all the
time with papers there's a problem with
this that or the other it all turns out
to be nonsense and what has happened in
the intervening week what has happened
in the interviewing what has happened in
the intervening week exactly
yeah i am glad you asked thank you
welcome zach you want to put up the uh
it's a letter to peter mccullough
in which the journal is explaining that
in fact they have rejected this paper
now rejecting a paper is not so unusual
but rejecting a paper after you have
accepted a paper is unusual no
explanation is given for why this is
taking place and what happens is that
the journal is simply asserting that
they have the right to do this
yes there's no explanation
so for those who are anyone read it oh
god i hate reading people are going to
be looking at my nose here i hate that
the screen is right up there i can get
them to close their eyes
dear dr mccullough this is dated october
21st thank you for your email of 15th of
october i am afraid that the journal is
not willing to publish the paper we do
not agree that there has been any sort
of breach here the publishing agreement
that was signed attached contains the
following clause which makes it clear
that articles may be rejected at a late
stage in the publication process
the editor's decision to project the
paper is final and all rights have
reverted to use that you are free to
submit the paper to another journal
and the paragraph on reversion of rights
reads articles may sometimes be accepted
for publication but later rejected in
the publication process even in some
cases after public posting in articles
in press form in which case all rights
will revert to the author c
link yours sincerely diana
so again i just want to emphasize how
unusual it is for no reason to be given
right it definitely suggests that
something has happened behind the scenes
and in light of the contentious nature
of the
phenomena in question
it appears to be the construction of the
appearance of consensus by the targeting
of anything that goes in the other
direction i mean among among other
things as as deeply flawed as peer
review is
had this paper been rejected at peer
review the authors would have been given
the three sets of comments by the peer
reviewers and they may have been banal
and cryptic and uninformative but there
would have been something there and
there
some justification is required when a
peer reviewer says no i don't think you
should publish this paper so here we had
you know two or three peer reviewers who
said yes publish the journal published
and then pulled it and there's no
there's not even any information that
would be found in you know largely not
very useful negative peer review there's
there's nothing i've actually just as
you said last week never heard of
anything like this now you know i'm not
in the weeds on peer review and journals
at this point but i was for many years
and this strikes me as
extraordinarily unusual right so i would
point out um
i accidentally borrowed a phrase from
eric that i didn't realize i had
borrowed at the time but the phrase is
follow the silence and in this case this
is a clear example what you've got now
is an absent journal article right a
journal article that points in the
direction of a pathology
following on from
vaccination that is worth knowing about
obviously whether or not to
mandate vaccines would require a
cost-benefit analysis which would
require us to know what the harms are to
be able to calibrate how common they are
how serious they are all of these things
it requires this evaluation and so in
any case what i would say is
it is intolerable
that
thoroughly qualified scientists and
doctors are having publications that
have passed peer review that have done
everything correctly eliminated from the
record before they even emerge without
explanation so we can't even evaluate
for ourselves whether or not this
journal has made some discovery that's
important about this publication or not
presumably it hasn't or it would have
said what the problem was
um so
in any case i think the point is
read the books that they want to burn
right that's the way that we win against
the censorship read the books that they
want to burn right seek out the stuff
that they don't want you to see talk to
the people that you're supposed to not
listen to right that is the way to
figure out whether there is something
there of importance or whether it truly
is nothing
[Music]
you